Combien de personnes s'ennuient à leur bureau
pendant combien d'heures par jour, de jours par semaine,
de semaines par an, et d'années de leur vie ?
[Petite chose]
[Grande idée]
[Daniel Engber à propos de la barre de progression]
La barre de progression n'est qu'un indicateur sur un ordinateur
qui signale une activité à l'intérieur de l'appareil.
La barre classique utilisée depuis des années est horizontale.
Ça remonte aux versions d'avant les ordinateurs, dans les registres
où on remplissait une barre horizontale de gauche à droite,
pour montrer l'état d'avancement d'une tâche dans une usine.
Il s'agit de la même chose mais sur un écran.
Dans les années 1970,
il y a eu, ce qu'on appelle parfois, « la crise du logiciel »,
où soudain, les ordinateurs sont devenus plus compliqués,
plus vite qu'on ne le pensait,
du point de vue de la conception.
Les indicateurs en pourcentage s'utilisaient de différentes manières.
On pouvait trouver un compte à rebours graphique
ou une ligne d’astérisques,
qui se remplissait de gauche à droite sur l'écran.
Mais personne n'avait fait de sondage systématique sur ces choses-là
et essayé de comprendre
quel est leur effet réel sur ce que perçoit l'utilisateur
assis devant son ordinateur ?
Brad Myers, étudiant en licence,
a décidé d'étudier ça en 1985.
Il a trouvé que le fait que l'indicateur
montre le pourcentage exact ou pas n'avait pas d'importance.
L'important était la présence même de la barre.
On se sentait mieux rien qu'en la voyant,
et c'était là le plus surprenant.
Il avait plein d'idées quant à ce que cette barre pouvait faire.
Elle pouvait nous aider à nous détendre de manière efficace.
Elle pouvait nous permettre de nous détourner de notre machine
et de faire autre chose pendant exactement la même durée.
On la regardait et on disait : « Oh, la barre de progression est à 50%.
Ça a pris cinq minutes.
Donc j'ai cinq minutes pour envoyer ce fax »,
ou pour faire toute autre chose qu'on faisait en 1985.
Ces deux choses sont fausses.
Quand on voit cette barre,
elle retient notre attention dans un rayon tracteur,
et elle transforme la perception de l'attente
en un récit passionnant qui se déroule devant nos yeux :
d'une manière ou d'une autre, ce temps d'attente frustrant
devant l'ordinateur qui exécute une tâche,
a été reconceptualisé ainsi :
« En cours ! Oh ! Il se passe des choses géniales ! »
[En cours...]
Mais quand on commence à voir la barre de progression
comme quelque chose qui atténue la pénibilité de l'attente,
on peut alors commencer à bidouiller la manière de la penser.
Donc si on a une barre de progression qui se déplace à un rythme constant --
disons que c'est ce qui se passe vraiment à l'intérieur de l'ordinateur --
on aura l'impression qu'elle ralentit.
On s'en lasse.
On peut désormais commencer à essayer de l'améliorer
et créer l'illusion qu'elle avance plus vite,
en la faisant bouger plus vite au début, comme une explosion de vitesse.
C'est excitant.
On penserait : « Oh ! Il se passe vraiment quelque chose ! »
On peut ensuite revenir à une barre de progression avançant plus naturellement
au fur et à mesure.
On suppose que les gens se concentrent sur le passage du temps --
ils essaient de regarder l'herbe pousser,
de regarder l'eau arriver à ébullition,
et on essaie seulement de rendre cela
moins ennuyeux, moins douloureux et moins frustrant
qu'il ne l'était avant.
Donc la barre de progression nous donne au moins
une vision du début et de la fin,
et on travaille vers un but.
Je pense qu'à certains égards, elle atténue la peur de la mort.
C'en est trop ?